las imágenes muestran al barco de guerra
chino cortando en perpendicular la
trayectoria del destructor
estadounidense mientras desde este Se le
pide por radio que deje de obstaculizar
la libertad de navegación el barco
estadounidense no varía el rumbo pero sí
reduce la velocidad y acaba pasando a
130 metros del Chino ocurrió este fin de
semana en el estrecho de Taiwán y es el
segundo incidente similar después de que
cazas de ambos países ya ejecutarán
maniobras arriesgadas la semana pasada
en el mar del sur de China Ese es el
gran peligro alertan los expertos de la
gran densidad de cazas y barcos en el
Pacífico que una colisión indeseada
acabe derivando en una guerra ambos
países se han culpado hoy de la
provocación dice Estados Unidos que solo
ejecuta rutinarias maniobras de libertad
de navegación y contesta china que con
esas maniobras solo pretende irritarla y
elevar la pensión añade que estos roces
siempre se producen frente a sus costas
y no frente a las costas estadounidenses
lo que bien claro quién está provocando
a quién el incidente y llega después de
que china a Estados Unidos subrayaran
este fin de semana en la Cumbre de
seguridad de Singapur todas sus
diferencias el representante chino
glisham Food rechazó la oferta de una
reunión bilateral de su homólogo
estadounidense Joy Austin alegando que
Washington no ha levantado las sanciones
que pesan sobre él ambos solo se han
puesto de acuerdo en afirmar que una
guerra entre China y Estados Unidos
sería un gran desastre para el mundo